Yes. Yeah right.
Although all the hippie
dimmer and all the.
Sort of drug drug culture
and and yuppies and all
that stuff lives over there for me personally
which is. 10 kilometers to the east.
And nimbin for me has
always been the sanctuary.
You know this this place is
abundance and plenitude where.
I learnt how to look up to the gardens
how to look after the horses.
How do i had a witness to
where they're coming over
and do all those country things
and you know probably above everything how
to look after myself my family you know
without all the added stresses of.
Of a full long occupational career
or or travelling or cars or traffic
or buildings or media or
communications and all those sort of.
Distorting and disturbing things you
know taking in big doses and so.
So what it is for me here is
a natural basis for living.
Which is beautiful enough not
to have to be invaded by by
civilisation and that's what you see
you know when you look out the window.
That's what you can see out there.
Well i think that i spent time in the city
and i thought i spent long enough
there to know what it was like.
I went to high school there
during my high school career
and you know growing up there. My father
lives down there not like down there so.
I mean. Thank god. When you've
got the best of both worlds.
You know you lucky enough to sort of have
the bit you know what the city can offer
and what the country can offer
but you know given the choice i think i
always choose what. What you have up here.
Cities great but i think the cities for.
It just seems like such a fragile place.
You know it's a sort of it's
a whole system of its own
that looks like it's on the verge
of constantly falling down.
And i wonder if one day it
will actually fall down
and all those people won't have
anywhere to go. I think. You know.
So this is where it's
at for me. My pleasure.
What i'd like to offer is a
conclusion to to all of this is that.
I think the media and
and general interest amongst australians
elsewhere has been a particularly
confrontational stranger
or frightening place
and i think what really is important
for people to understand now is that.
Is that nimbin is integrating
and is becoming much more much
more than what would people
would normally think and i think
that's what's important about it
that it needn't be this
unique or special or mystical
or transcendent place
at all which it isn't
but just be a a beautiful
haven for people to come to
when they want to you know.
Absolutely yeah. They've actually.
And they've actually been able to
blend so much into mainstream media
and understanding in communications
that yeah they've overlaps now
and i think the thing about nimbin as
it's not it's not going to perform
that role too much in the future anymore.
Sure it's got a permaculture hammered
and it's called her live energy systems
which is very much technological
developments but the whole.
Ethical and spiritual and societal
influence which nimbin has had a.
These is not so much.
The issue anymore
and i don't think people should
should have false expectations are
that.
Sure if not prefer if not prophetical
visionary it's there's a stereotypical image
of of ultra ultra decadence or ultra
self-indulgence altar. Ultra nihilism.
You know existentially angst sort
of floating around the place
and sure that's true but but
isn't that the same everywhere
and it is not sort of nimbin just
a reflection of any anywhere else
and i mean you can walk
down 20 places in sydney
and see a microcosm of what nimbin
is you know just in urban terms.
So i think nimbin is always
held this this sort of.
Intriguing mysterious role in
australian society since the early 70s
and i think now it's time for
people who are out there
and living in in conservative
suburban homes to realise that
that the changes got to
start happening from there.
Now you know newman's alright but it's
just it's going to sort of grow along
and you know sort of happily develop into
a senile obsolescence you know while ever
everything else just keeps on blowing
up and i think that's important for.
For suburban people for people who live out
there amongst amongst millions of other
people to understand that that
it's important to learn how to.
How to organize their lives
in a more ethical and
and sound way.
I hope i do so. Throw forces
of december you know to.
Speaking with gloria constrain
can you see o n s t i n e
t o when i'm gloria constrained.
And i work at the nimbin news.
Well i've been in the mean
about you know 10 to 11 years.
I visited nimbin for two years
before that and sassed it out
and use a do a paper in melbourne
before i came up here.
So it was pretty relevant to get
in get involved with an image use
which i did about. Or between
eight and nine years ago.
Just doing different things.
Interviews and what have you.
This year old. Now it's much bigger.
So you are the. The.
The difference between this paper
and the paper i did before was
that there's an office immoralities and
that is that they're all voluntary
that you don't get paid or anything.
This is just bigger and
it's more involved in this.
Wider wider range of topics. Yeah.
Can you.
Oh see if they were reading it for
the first time i suppose you get an
overview or you get a an insight
into what's happening to our nimbin.
We get lots of letters come in in some of.
Criticising different
aspects of the society and.
Replies to that but.
Just different letters
from different people
that gives a good idea of
what's happening and we also.
We edit material out of other
magazines that we swap with.
So that the most up to date. It
information it's like really.
I a p of nimbin if you like we will edit
out all the information you think's
important that people should
know and get that in there.
We want to educate people.
So as to work.
Yeah i can do that.
I k the sources who are we've got plenty
of sources this social alternative organic
news to me. Chain reaction.
I otoh from japan. Silver cord this one.
The whole person. Animals agenda for.
Columbia some of these are
from overseas sof technology.
Because grab newsletter. Down to earth.
Elemental. Nexis first garden
there are you name it.
I mean we get them always great.
So much.
Are male. I really know.
Asking miles today is no mind you get
quite a bit get quite a bit of you know
the end of month we get the magazines come
and in the monthlies we also get a lot of
we seem to be on somebodies list which i
wish we weren't we get all these
media releases of beauty products
and pet things and you
know i mean all the stuff
that we're really not interested in.
Oh you know they just send all of this stuff
i mean it was even a purchase sent to
the mail which you couldn't even
undo the class but. I just me.
I really wish they did so the time. Yes
off their list and save their money.
You know.
Why we don't know who's put us on
some list but obviously with air
and we get all this stuff we've net stuff
from telecom which wasn't too bad i
suppose that you know i mean
we hear from them anyway.
Each time when they want their money.
Now i just resent being on on a list
of which gives people they've got the
impression that the stuff
that they're sending in these is is getting
you know having noticed taken over
when you know it just gets put in the.
Unsolicited media releases.
Pile and that's where it stays.
Through. Yeah i know if this civil.
Problem though we were sending them back
at first but they still sent them out.
I mean we say we get something from them
every week people we get stuff every week
you know if incredible. Not much of the
stuff we can that we can use at all.
In fact very very little. World.
I think you know it's an australian list
obviously we're not getting stuff from
elsewhere. You know.
What's in the sort of
covered in the region.
You know through.
Topics.
Well we get lots and lots of
power tree which is great.
Really nice way of expressing yourself and
apparently you can't get sued. Health.
You know forestry forest
problems you know.
Then the environment is a predominance
you know having a say in ecology.
If a logical movement.
You know trying to find the best
ways of doing things are things
that ways of doing things information
of the ways of doing things
that is not going to pollute
the environment and.
Send us to our destruction
which i think is something
that that's affecting everybody even if
they don't talk about it very much is still
a sort of a depressing thought
to think that you know.
The world as we know it
might not be viable. For.
For the end of our lifetimes
amount about the future.
Local issue.
So yeah there's there are
fairly heavy debates.
We we just give give people the
opportunity to debate that
that in the paper.
I think it is there's always
a tendency that people.
Don't miss train themselves to the
actual issue rather than they tend
to attack the person which is you know.
Not the best way to do things
the issue is is what's at stake
not whether you. Put somebody
down or make somebody feel silly.
Extreme free press.
Well it's not as i mean we don't treat
everything that comes in a some stuff.
We were given some stuff from a guy. Mr.
Ping actually who went to where was he
got he was overseas somewhere south
america and we sent in a staff and there.
I mean we've seen this
copious amounts of stuff
that we couldn't we couldn't
get any make any sense of.
While he was in australia and when he went
to south america. He sent us more so.
But. Sorry.
So you know.
He hasn't sent them for why i
think maybe you got the message
but he was attacking other people in his
letters too so you know i got bit personal.
Politics and politics
and passion.
Was the local politics.
Yeah yeah there's there's lots
of different cliques and groups
and people. Different ideas
different ideas all over the place.
There's no range from the super very
cool to the super straight if you like
beyond i suppose but within that range.
Is is an indonesian democratic
democratic or most i don't
know about democratic.
I like it and they can
and i think anarchistic
they make them ok i say
anarchistic democracy.
I don't know that i could put
the two words together. But.
It depends on how many how
my how much you can blab.
And to whom will you know who will
listen to you as to how good you do in
the political political
stuff you know there's.
There's politics and
politics is dirty politics
and this getting your message
across. You know in the day.
Three politics is alive and.
Next week's.
Was the word.
Well exploit work exploitation
is exploiting the situation but.
A situation can happen and
lies and exaggerations.
Become was heard and.
If you don't have an opportunity
to you know if you got the time
or the inclination to go blab blab in
as much as what the opposition has.
Then you sunk.
As usual.
For. Shonky cancers.
It's all over everything
even a great move.
Mr jones. Mr jones.
You know that this is going to fare well
that was. That was pretty incredible.
I people come out to me in the street
saying i don't trust fact guy you know.
He's a bit suss and i mean i knew that
but i mean our strategy our policy was
that you know if anybody wants to work
on the name in you say come on with it
and he was willing to do some
working so you sort of came.
This was a time before you just
as we would get in our mail box
and mailbox we were these receiving mail
for this person before we were to see even
any mail for us and. He was he
had great plans of doing a.
Four for the alternative press. You
know lismore alternative place.
It was going to be. And. He
was going to be governor.
Going to get a c p grant
of half a million dollars.
Yet people can't paper when they
had a factory vented in this more
and had no sort of nothing really to back
him up because they were on investigation
there was no c p e p grant and.
Anyway then he got to me that. Paid.
Registered the name women
using his name and i mean.
You know you should have
been registered years ago.
I mean nobody i wasn't even aware
that you know registration had to happen
even you know it all those things were
taken care of the time.
He found out
that it wasn't registered an imagist
to do in his name classifying boney's.
And i tricked him into admitting it.
I said you know how much it cost to register
the name women using your name in your
name. How much it cost to
register and him in years and.
He said or i mean were how much it
was but whatever it was 60 bucks.
You know you whose name did you
register in you know my name.
I just like i said dirty
low down trick isn't it.
If you know how comes you know done in
your name. Ice's well that's business.
That's business.
With the shadow the shoulders
and the arms are prized.
So anyway i told him just his name
was going to be made from now on
and he better clear off and bring e his
keys in and bring his keys in first
and then clear off because he
wouldn't be taken seriously anymore.
And.
I actually. The first prime bow news
that came out we were trying to sort of.
Become.
Financial by being in a paper each month
which was going to be alternately the
women news and rainbow
news. So the first round.
I knew that was the next
one that was coming up
and it couldn't wait for the following
one which would be the nimby news.
So i sort of printed
something about it in there
but we eventually got the news
registered in our name after
that will be a fire.
There's lots of mr. jones is out there.
I don't think we want to show his face.
What sort of structure. To
make it work. It's all about.
Oh yes it's still voluntary
although we do have blessings.
Some of our over time i think is.
Swapped for vouchers that enable
us to go and say you know best.
Ron have a massage of the pictures or
something like that. Not very much.
I mean only a very small amount that
that just makes little bit
of icing on the cake for us.
You know apart from being out
the paper we can do that
but.
Yeah. Hardly.
But then yeah. Well stressful. I used
to be stressful it's not anymore.
It's working really really well right now
we've got a great group working together
we. The stuff that comes in.
Either or even the stuff that gets
chosen out of the paper so that it's.
We try and take the power out
of positions. If you like.
We don't have an editor and
sabaidee so you know this and
that we just sort of do what we
can and what needs to be done
and we get the paper out and.
You know some of us get better other thing
you know certain things like oh you know
i don't go near the computer but.
Other people who are you know will
we bang the computer and stuff like
that anyway we.
Stuff that comes in we put
it up on the board and
when it's three once i see people voting
for it going to paper then it's potest
going to the paper there might be
stuff there that might get to ones
and twos threes so you know if
you put a three on it means
that you know not recommended.
There's a two which means
that it's a possibility if there's you
know if you start for a filler which we.
When. Not usually we've got
so much stuff on the board.
You know that that could go in that.
We don't really need fillers
but it may need to be a tv hit
or something may need to be done to it.
To make except a ball to go in
or it may be relevant to put it in you know
like might be some kind of food flytrap
or something which is
silly put in the winter
when nobody's thinking
at all about food life.
Yeah yeah yeah.
And of course the the
local stuff the letters
and the stuff they've sent
in there's more emphasis on
that there's more has a higher
priorities and any reprinted stuff.
And that goes in. I know
there's an objection to it.
We try and see everything before it goes
in some time and we. There's such a lag.
You know if somebody
is very slow to get in
and we don't even see it before it
goes in and that's only happened once
and there's been a problem with that. So.
We like to be able to see
and i say some make sure nobody's
doing anything daft at least.
In their writing that can get
us and them into trouble.
But it's you know i'm fair enough
if it was stuff put into light
and we don't have a chance to pose
a threat but we've got this space
that we've you know we've got
to get it to the printer.
Oh yeah sure. Yeah. Although some people
prefer not to apply and just sort of.
Black and black list anybody
associated with the paper
or you know i mean they're
so that maybe my paranoia.
Is just for. Yeah yeah we've got
subscriptions who are over the place.
We've got enough subscriptions so it's
probably not pushing as much as we could
but. We've even got more one
subscriptions from overseas.
I know too there's a
lively for overseas and.
Yeah we get subscriptions and all over.
We've just been working on our
tides and we're getting in.
We're getting five together of our total
archives which is an horrendous job.
That one of our work is known
as been working on and.
He's doing a magnificent job
just saw in these papers
that we lugged around from place to place
you know all these boxes and boxes
and boxes of paper.
You did. Of the offices.
Will in the time i've been with it.
We've we've been under the town hall
and that was a real rammy place.
Like. This was a very nice.
It always very ganji as there was you
know there's a floor above us and it.
When he walked on the floor then you get
all this stuff coming through the ceiling.
It was horrible. Everything
was covered in a lot.
I mean you know you clear
away you know and.
You know.
Our head out there you know i mean you
know i can think you know i'm sure
that somewhere in india there
was something someplace worth.
But i mean it was good
to be able to be there
and it was a it was a start for
us we didn't have any money.
We couldn't pay when we were in
town which was very good and.
I mean my aversion to god is not sort
of necessarily everybody's problem.
And then we then we vented a boom from
the. Community school which really nice.
Spent about a year there i think
maybe a little bit longer
but then i went away. On
the peace train i think.
Then
when i came back we were all packed up
underneath the tomato sauce factory because
the school needed their
room. We had nowhere to go.
So then we managed to get a house
the brown house it tenable falls
and. We.
We moved in there and that was really good
a whole house ourselves it was amazing.
We've got the phone on. Wow.
I was really coming up in the world
and we got a printing press from the.
An op shop actually and got this going.
He was an offset printing press.
And yeah we got that going in and had
that going for a while was pretty
pretty hard work and set up the office
and you know just just tried our way in
to get in heaven a little bit of money
and paying the bills and they never.
We think to pay the workers at all.
And now we've got this. We were
there about three years and now.
Now six years which is what
was the time go so fast
and six years we were there and
now we're in this office in town.
Behind sam's organic food shop
and it's great to be in the sun and
that it is very compact we've got to
really organize organize ourselves
and can't have big furniture or anything.
And functions and where we're so now.
We're managing to make it so
that it works for us here.
Problem. Or a circular structural.
Pyramid a non hierarchical
structure and yeah.
I don't because you know we all
treat each other really well
actually.
Specially this group is presently here.
It's taken a long while but we are taking
power the power out of positions and
that is that you know the editor doesn't
sort of. Pull it pushes wait around.
I never body else we all make the
decisions we have meetings about things
and you know if we've got to going to
spend more than a hundred bucks we make a
decision about it
and if we're going to make a change in
the present strategy we make a decision
about it. We don't sort of
people don't sort of assume
that something's going to happen and
and do it and drag everybody along.
So make decisions about it.
So you know where you go in what
you do and if you wanna take part.
You do anything.
Don't you don't know.
The year. Well or they are going.
I think it's going really well.
Financially it's paying its
bills with our went up.
Twofold she filed. For me leaving
tangible to come in here.
But.
We've organized ways of overcoming
you know an increase in advertising
and of course the other
ties in the main income.
Yeah we just make sure
that you know that we.
What we get enough coming in to pay the
bills. That there isn't this as a side.
Taken
that step to actually be in financial as
far as paying people is another matter.
That is. Nowhere near in sight.
So yeah everybody works ok.
Yeah we are really good.
This is good to be able to actually
put your skills to some use.
And produce something that is really good
that people can actually in
the streets they are nothing
when you really good their best
yet you know the last six times
that people have been saying it's the
best yet. So it must be improving.